[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eight-time all-star
couple of cy youngs and one last night
and uh the dodgers won 9-2 they won
eight straight 12 of their last 13. they
beat
the astros clayton kershaw joining us on
the program clayton uh congrats on the
win last night
i was talking about strange injuries i
don't know if you heard zach pleaseak
broke his thumb after aggressively
taking off his
jersey what's the strangest baseball
injury
you've ever witnessed man that's a very
aggressive shirt take off
how do you do that i don't know i don't
know
man you know you hear about the you hear
about the broken hands like hitting the
you know hitting a water cooler or um
you know i think that somebody's like
stubbed their toe and broke their toe
like running into a table late at night
trying to go the bathroom i think that's
that could happen to me at any moment so
that's that one that one resonated with
me
would you ever make up an excuse just
because you suffered an injury that
could be
viewed as embarrassing maybe not
embarrassing but like
i think potentially you know if you're
hooping it up and
you know maybe tearing acl or something
you might want to think of something
else like oh i was doing box jumps or
working out you know you might not want
to say i was
you know on the court and tore an acl or
something
are you allowed to play basketball
during the season you're
i think the rule is you're not allowed
to play like
an organized league but i think you're
allowed i'm probably this is probably
gray area but i think you're allowed to
play like pickup games
but still if you get hurt you're pr
that's probably not good you probably
shouldn't do it
but do you does each contract have
similar language of what you're allowed
to do and not allowed to do
yeah i think they all have like they
have a whole list of things you can't do
like
skiing and there's some weird ones in
there um
like they i i forget what else there is
but i know skiing is a big one
but yeah every like uniform contract has
a bunch of things you can't do
for sure what was the atmosphere like
last night and was it
what you expected last night i'll tell
you what there's so many dodger fans
there last night it was it was really
cool
um they they traveled so well they had a
whole section
like down the right field line and then
sprinkled in throughout the whole
stadium
um it was the first night ironically
that houston allowed a max crowd
so that was uh i'm sure they didn't do
that on purpose but that was uh that was
pretty cool to see how many dodger fans
were there last night it was awesome
but does does it matter to you like you
beat them
but it doesn't take away the sting of
anything that's happened prior to this
does it
yeah i mean if you if you ask me rather
win last night or win
game five of the world series i probably
would pick that one you know
but uh i think uh you know i think
mentally coming back here and
um pitching well and you know getting a
win i think there's
i don't know there's a little bit of
closure in that for me a little bit but
yeah it doesn't take anything away and i
said that last night you're not gonna
change what happened in the past and
um but you know to come back here the
first time
and pitch here since that happened i
think there's um
you know i think there's a little bit of
closure that coupled with winning last
year i think
you know helps you know i know it helps
me mentally a lot for sure
yeah i was wondering about that that if
you didn't win last year
then that probably exacerbates this it
makes it
you know stand out and hurt or haunt a
little bit more
yeah it makes it harder for sure makes
it harder um
definitely not something that um i
wanted to do coming back here and not
having one one
so that was that was it definitely
alleviated a lot of some things it
doesn't take it away
you know like you said but um it
definitely helped for sure
talking to clayton kershaw after the win
last night i think you said recently
maybe last week that uh no hitters
aren't great for baseball am i
paraphrasing you correctly
no i don't think that's exactly what i
said i said no hitters are great for
baseball but
i think the great thing about is unique
it's hard to do
and it still is incredibly hard to do um
i was probably a little harsh last week
but
it just seems like it has happened every
night you know and um
some sometimes the great things about
baseball are that they're so rare
and they're so hard to accomplish so
when you're seeing guys
you know no hitter watch every night i
don't know if that's the best thing
but no hitters are still great they're
super cool i just
they're more cool when they happen less
frequently
well also i i don't know if pictures are
it's not like you know you're greg
maddox and you're nibbling on the
corners that feels like these guys are
just
saying here it is let's see if you can
hit it and the hitters are going
throw it let me see if i can hit it and
maybe that's
like i'm trying to understand why we're
getting no hitters and these aren't
necessarily hard
throwing guys so how would you
how would you sum that up of that we've
had you know
this many no-hitters yeah i think that's
a bigger conversation
i think there's a lot of factors in that
you know like you said i think some guys
um like corey kluber for example corey
is a pitcher
like he he doesn't throw 100 miles per
hour
he has a bunch of different pitches that
he knows how to execute
and when he's going good you know that
stuff like that can happen
and then you have other guys just pure
stuff just dominating guys
um with you know all the spin rates and
you know
velocity and things like that so
pitching is
pitching is really really good right now
just across the league
and hitting i still think hitting is the
hardest thing to do in sports
and so as pitching continues to get
better
and evolve and different things like
that hitting
you know has come to a point where
they're trying to hit home runs and
it's not any fault of their own that's
what you get paid to do you don't get
paid to hit singles anymore so
it's a huge full circle thing when teams
start paying guys to get on base
and hit singles and not strike out then
guys might start changing their approach
a little bit more but
when you get paid to hit home runs and
slug and you're not really worried about
hitting the two strike single the other
way you're gonna have a lot of gains
where you strike out 15
and have some no hitters does it help
you at all as a pitcher
to when you go to the plate like can you
can you tell what's coming your way like
a catcher i always thought a catcher
would be
a good hitter because he's so used to
seeing these pitches in the spin and
and everything that goes along with it i
i know it doesn't equate to that but
can you tell what's coming i know you
still have to hit it
yeah i can tell i think i guess right
like 75 percent of the time
when i'm hitting but i just can't hit it
i'm just not that skilled
um it doesn't it i think it helps a
little bit
to make contact but at the end of the
day hitting's just really hard
it's just it's coming really fast it's
just it's just really fast
but when somebody throws if i through 95
and somebody else threw a hundred how
big of a difference is that when you're
at the plate
it's yeah you know it's it's different
person to person as weird as that sounds
um like i faced so the last couple guys
that i say i faced sunny grey maybe two
weeks ago and sunny
he throws like 93-94 and that was the
fastest
like fastest fastball i had seen and i
don't know if it's because he's a little
bit shorter and
like it just explodes that like i don't
know why but that's why pitching is so
unique is that everybody is so different
and sometimes 93 feels like it's
150 and sometimes i face some guys that
are throwing 97 that
it doesn't feel that fast and it's just
the deception of it or i don't know
but sunny gray i had absolutely no
chance to hit a baseball
what's the fastest you've ever been
clocked on the gun
[Applause]
back in my back in my youthful days i
might have gotten i think maybe 98 the
hardest i've ever thrown
is there a temptation to want to throw
harder
yeah i'd love to throw harder for sure
but but you know maddox was a a power
pitcher and then he became
i mean he was a thrower and then he
became a pitcher you know just
that he kind of graduated to that is
that
yeah i mean the best the best pitchers
in the game are the ones that throw
really hard
and know how to pitch so the jacob de
grams of the world the garrett coles of
the world
um the walker buellers of the world you
know those guys
um have the dominant electric 97-98
in the groms case 102 mile an hour
fastballs but they just put it exactly
where they want to
and they know how to pitch and so that's
why
the great thing about that is you can
throw 90 miles per hour and if you know
how to pitch still have success so
thankfully for some of us older fellows
you can still do that
how do you explain jacob degrom i don't
i
i want i've talked to him about it i
have no idea um
i it's just a reverse aging curve i
don't get it
um i don't get it but it's it's pretty
special to watch and
man he's such a great dude i really like
him he uh he's fun to watch um
i you can't explain it i have no idea
and
like i love watching scherzer pitch
because he he just
pounds it like he's just saying here it
comes and he and he also has great stuff
i mean there
there are a few of those pictures but
there's just something about them you
know what you do how you do it
degrom but those they're more power
pictures
like scherzer fascinates me um degrom i
i don't know how to describe that it's
it's and imagine if he got any offensive
support
yeah he some of those numbers about his
no decisions and things like that are
just amazing
that's just sometimes you pitch on the
right day and sometimes you don't
and so but with with max i love watching
max pitch too you know i think
just competitor you know i think is the
first word that comes to my mind you
just you just
feel them competing out there and
there's just a few guys for me that you
like i would i would pay money to watch
pitch
and those two are right at the top of
the list
we have a lot of guys on our team that i
feel that way about and
i think that's what makes baseball great
is to have fun starting pitching
match-ups that you can go and watch and
say oh
sure is reversed to grom today or you
know bueller versus
um i'm trying to think of anybody else
but yeah just different guys like that
that it's just fun to watch
what are your career numbers against
albert pujols
i know i have not given up a homer but i
think he's hitting like 320 off me
but i know i haven't given up a homer so
i'll take that and there's no chance
you're gonna give up a homer to him this
year so i think you're safe
i think you're one of the few that
escaped albert pools
hey you know that was the first hit i
ever gave up dan was to albert pujols
did you know at the time about albert
pujols or what did you know
yeah he was pretty good he was pretty
good yeah i knew
i knew okay thank you oh thank you it
was good
do you remember the remember the pitch
yeah it was actually a curveball 3-2
curveball and it was my so it was my
it was my debut and i struck out the
first batter and then i walked the next
pattern on four pitches
and then albert poogle hit a double and
scored a run and i was like well this is
not going great
well plus it's gone a lot better since
then but like
do you look over to the on deck circle
and you see pujols over there um
but yeah like my opening my debut i was
too nervous to even
i didn't even know what was going on
yeah i didn't i just was trying to throw
somewhere near the strike zone do we
have a rivalry with the padres
is it official sure yeah
if that helps i mean if that's if that's
what we want to call it
you know i the padres are really good
they're a great team
and i think it's going to come down to
the wire in september
and you can't leave out the giants the
giants are playing really well right now
so
between you know us and those two teams
it's going to be
it's going to be a fun summer um and
we've got our work cut out for us for
sure
i think i have tatis on the show next
week any message you'd like to uh
send it uh no
no he's uh if he wants to cool down
that'd be great if he wants to take
you know like a week off or something
that'd be great when we play him
how annoying is it having matthew
stafford in l.a like are you have you
had enough of him you tired of stafford
now
i think everybody else is tired of
hearing about us huh did you know he
went to high school together
and now and now he's in the same town
with you
oh i know i'm excited for him though i
really am i think he
he's just uh it's exactly you know i
texted him after he got traded and i
just said
you know i hope it's what you wanted you
know because sometimes when you get
traded you don't really have a choice um
but he was so fired up he's so excited
to
um get out there and get going and the
rams are gonna be a fun team to watch
and
so i'm excited to watch him it's gonna
be great
but he didn't stay at your house when he
first got out there right
no you know i think he has has the means
to find out
yeah yeah i he's my sneaky super bowl or
my sneaky mvp pick this year what do you
think
yeah he's i just i really am i'm excited
and uh
he you know he's got a lot left in the
tank and
he really wants to win and i think it's
a good pick i think it's a good pick
but did you get rid of all your lions
gear
uh yeah i didn't have too much lines
gear i had a hat
so yeah i'll probably get rid of the hat
you had a
hat as support well what did stafford
have of
the dodgers what do you want me to do
where is jersey
i'm not going to wear his jersey around
i'll wear i'll wear a hat and support
you guys went to high school together
now you sound like everybody else
come on you're ruining the storyline
what's wrong with you clayton
i think i'm probably doing the people a
favor yeah you
are i don't know what people are going
to be able to talk to you about now that
uh you know they're going to talk about
the world series or uh
you know you turn 33 in march
yeah anything else is great all right i
hope the family's well it's always great
to talk to you thank you
and uh play nice in houston okay all
right
thanks dan appreciate it that's clayton
kershaw